I have IDC, Dr. Carson Oma breast cancer.
The past month my breasts have been swollen and very tender.
My legs are also swollen and I had hambed for a few years.
Is this indicated my lymphatic system is not draining properly?
What can I do to alleviate these swelling?
Lastly, do you have any recommendations for integrative oncologists?
Integrative MD in the Twin Cities metro area.
Okay, so with swollen legs with swelling and increased tenderness in the breast, can this be an indication of the lymphatic system not draining properly?
Yes, it can be.
So what can you do to alleviate these?
Well, there's lots of things. So let's talk about those lots of things.
So first of all, what you think about is doing things that will decrease swelling.
So you could run the swelling program on the right.
There's also a program that's called inflammation on the right.
You can run these right programs there in the alphabetical listings of the right that you'll find and run those programs.
So that's one thing that you could do.
Also understand the swelling and what it is.
You want to do everything you can to decrease inflammation through nutrition.
So different nutrition that will help with swelling would be the flavonoids. So we're talking as well here.
That's good for that curcubin.
That's good for that resveratrol.
That's good for swelling white willow bark.
EGCG from green tea extract. That's good for swelling.
So anything that will don't these are the flavonoids that are also good for pain because so much pain is caused by swelling.
They work for that as well.
So nutrition that could help with that.
Also to help with lymphatic detoxification, you can do lymphatic massages.
So if you go to a massage therapist that's trained in cancer therapy, massages, you can get a lymphatic massage.
You can also understand that we talked about these the last couple of zoom calls about the lymphatic system doesn't have a heart that pumps things through.
So any type of exercises would help with lymphatic detoxification, even just muscle contraction getting up doing some like razors going up on your toes.
You're going down right to alphabet with your with your with your toes, just contracting muscles helps with movie live.
So any muscle contraction is the key.
So anything you can do that involves muscle contraction will help with motion. So getting up and doing some arm curls.
You don't have to do barbells. You just need to do some little bit of calisthenics. That's going to help move things through.
Anti-inflammatory diet can be helpful decrease in anything that could be inflammatory. How do we know if it's something that's inflammatory to me specifically.
Well, then you got to think about things that maybe foods that maybe causing inflammation that you maybe have sensitivity so you have antibodies to different foods.
How do you know that you could run a Syrex test that would be a Syrex array 10 panel or you could eliminate the most common things one of the most common things that are inflammatory foods that would be gluten dairy eggs think of things like that meat.
Well, I'm already on such a restricted diet. Okay, well, then think of the things above that. So there's a lot of different things that you could do to help increase the lymphatic detoxification work on the liver do hot packs over the liver do coffee animals.
Nobody wants to do coffee animals. Coffee animals can be really good to help you detoxify and get things moving.
Do I have recommendations for integrated oncologists integrated MD in the Twin Cities. I don't not that's integrated with cancer. There's some natural MDs in the Twin Cities, but they don't deal with cancer per se.
So I don't have any integrated oncologist ideas. We don't know of anybody personally in the Twin Cities.